OSCAR DE LA HOYA:
The world fell in love
with my story.
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
But it was a lie.
ANNOUNCER: The pride of
East LA, the Golden Boy.
SPEAKER:
Oscar De La Hoya was
the most popular fighter
since Muhammad Ali.
I've never told anybody
what really happened.
At six years old,
out come the gloves.
-(BELL DINGS)
-Started fighting kids.
Punched in the face.
My father told me,
"Be tough!
You're gonna take us out
of this lifestyle."
That's a lot of pressure.
SPEAKER 2: He said he was
gonna be champion of the world.
(CHILDREN LAUGHING)
OSCAR: What are you
laughing at?
This is my dream.
I'm gonna show you.
Before my mother passed away,
she told me she wanted
the gold medal.
OSCAR: I was on a mission
to make history.
I'm 24, making 20 million
dollars a fight.
There was nobody bigger.
I was hanging out with
beautiful women.
I felt like a star.
ANNOUNCER 2: Everything
De La Hoya touches
has turned to gold.
OSCAR: The golden left hook.
The golden story.
But truth always comes out.
And I knew it would come back
to haunt me.
Money changes everything.
SPEAKER 3: Nothing he said
to me was the truth.
OSCAR: My dream
became a nightmare.
All this anger.
I have to free myself.
I won 11 world titles
in six different weight classes.
I want to be that hero.
I can see myself fighting,
and I don't even know
why I'm fighting.
Who in the fuck am I?
♪ (INTENSE STRINGS PLAY) ♪